is half a point outside top eight
only half a point and here we go here we
go it's a queen's pawn opening
magnus pushing that pawn forward he
hasn't been experimenting too much with
the weird and wacky openings
throughout this tournament i wonder what
magnus will do here will it be
queen's gambit will it be the london
system to do play openings that my
opponents are
special but okay london calling it is
the london system
you're right ivanka has done his
homework here because kukesh we saw him
in the gelfand challenge
he won the final round the crucial game
he has a
large choice and he brings his bishop
out i guess normal would have been to
push some pawns but instead he brings
his bishop out
that tends to be a bad bishop sometimes
locked behind its own pawns
how do you think he's going to do that
your anchor what's he done in the past
he develops his bishop i thought he was
going to push a pawn there
you thought knight i thought pawn he
played bishop he played bishop
and then we do see a trade of bishops
early on you can put your knight into
the center and then you can start
attacking well respected
and magnus had the opportunity to grab a
pawn there and he didn't go for it
you don't want to give young players any
energy in their position you don't want
to give them something to hope for
black upon down but with a nice active
rook cash playing quickly so far
that's the key for him i think okay he
does play pawn takes pawn
i that's just magnus's style he doesn't
want things to get blocked up too
congested he wants a clear plan
and now after the bishop recaptures
which i expect then white
might castle and then he'll use his own
pawns to undermine black's strong center
okay and meanwhile
we do have a decision and this critical
moment by gakesh he doesn't recapture
his pawn
he just brings his knight out saying to
magnus okay you're reporting up but it's
only temporary
kokesh really posing questions the world
champion at this early stage and
since the first year uh huey fun game
finally finished we now have the
standings can i take the standings or
should we address this
so magnus trying to defend his pawn and
going on the attack with his queen but
there are consequences in previous tour
events in uh
in the six previous events eight and a
half tends to be completely safe
eight and a half out of fifteen so with
three games left eight and a half you're
very happy not showing any fear and uh
yeah
getting some great wins along the way
meanwhile black is still a pawn down
though on this board and magnus has
developed his knight
it's not actually easy to win back that
pawn if we
just bring up that analysis board we see
that white's extra pawn it is a doubled
pawn
these two pawns on the sea line kind of
get in each other's way and right now
this is a bit of a lone ranger it's only
defended by white's queen and look at
this
kukesh he's pushing a pawn forward
trying to eliminate the defender of
this pawn but if magnus wants to cling
to it he can step forward
the bishop okay he does that he still
can't uh
take this pawn this bishop this bishop
is dreaming of taking this pawn but it
can't quite yet and now
there's two ways that i see to try and
maybe regain
this pawn the most tempting though is to
actually drop back with the black queen
to create this square
and white has to be careful as well you
okay he finds the best move i think
there gokesh
he is so impressive this teenager and
white has to be careful if you push a
pawn forward to try and defend your
pawns
watch out you might actually maybe not
this move immediately but uh yeah
actually here you're just about to get
your queen trapped you can maybe try and
exchange queens and beg
and hope that you're okay but uh magnus
he has to be what
uh careful himself like what's going to
happen like i mean if you just try to
move your knight
to the edge of the board oh doesn't it
it happens but
dukakesh is just going to retreat right
queen only has one safe square now
that's the only square and she's going
to well kakesh is going to
take this pawn i actually really like
kakashi
if he retreats his knight as he does um
so he cleared that square
for his uh night last move with that
queen retreat that queen retreat was
very impressive because
no he steps forward magnus finds a
different square he offers a queen trade
but
that doesn't look ambitious at all i
mentally reverse the position
round plan i see it's a very subtle plan
okay but it's definitely something that
usually you do with colors reverse when
you have the black side of things
you know is this happening it's almost
the same almost identical instead
kukesh traded the queens and then he
went with the bishop to capture here
that white is going to lack space later
in the year and i like the fact that he
did it
he kept the two nights on the board
because you know again
it's another another case in point
for the two of a kind do you know he's
uh fond of going for those quick draws
and it looks like for us yeah i'm
against who you fan
um black against wesley so it's probably
one of it's one of the toughest pairings
in the tournament for sure so
faruzia playing safety first there and
uh i really like what gakesh has done
he's pushing pawns on the left side he's
now pushed upon on the other side
getting ready to kind of use a square
for the black king
all these kind of small factors again
but it is all in
all in um black's favor and that last
move by magnus shows that he's on the
defensive
one fine day perhaps pushing
this is this was my the sneaky idea that
i had in mind
so the whole idea with maneuvering the
knight to this particular square
is that perhaps you can push
a pawn on the left side of the board one
square
and then i know he he wants to make a
use of his bishop
i think yeah magnus should not touch any
pawns on that left side
you shouldn't play pawns on the side
that you're weaker that's where black's
knights lie
i think that would only maybe create
weaknesses that help push you to that
next level but
i know a lot of young kids nowadays they
say oh this looks like a plus one
position but
that means nothing plus one can mean ten
different things and
that's not how you should learn the game
when magnus just had the center and was
just very comfortable with
absolutely everything and just look at
this very nice move by gukesh just
calmly pushing a pawn yeah okay magnus
forced
into passivity he's just i mean he's
just moving a rook
just creating some space for his other
rook to use uh
use some squares but yeah that's not an
active move that's a little bit uh
there's a kind of move where your spider
senses start to tingle and you think oh
you know are there any forcing moves
because i'm just looking at the pattern
of that position i'm like the rook and
the king that's
vulnerable to a night fork so if i were
to clear the path
maybe something could happen yeah and
now magnus has
found a good square for his other rook
at least but you're right you've anchor
uh that white rook on on the sea lion it
looks awfully shaky it's not defended
and that's when your kind of your radar
your spidey senses start tingling
uh when there are undefended pieces in
your opponent's camp and
okay bukesh he's starting to up the
speed at least on the clock
his last few moves have been kind of
vague moves pushing harry the h point
ups
a couple of squares taking space now
bringing his king towards the center
no immediate breakthrough no immediate
plan but just following that
decent strategy of improving pieces
and okay we do hear a move wow yeah that
just shows that magnus
he has no plan he brought his rook to
the center on a semi-open line
nothing to do there he's brought it back
frank on that fifth row all of them
i mean is he going to continue stepping
forward with the pawns okay now he's
pushing a different pawn
that's a committal but it does make some
sense he's trying to box in
white's dark square bishop so he's
putting pawns to light squares instantly
capturing that pawn i perhaps would have
taken
some time over that capture tarash who
said that weak squares in your
opponent's camp should be occupied by
pieces not pawns and
that's what kukesh will try to do magnus
cannot sit still any longer he has to
take some action yeah key issue in the
position you know because like david
says
white is threatening to capture the pawn
and now once
the black knight moves well the
protection
over the central pawn has been released
so now good cash has to be incredibly
accurate and i think
this is definitely the best move off the
board
because now knight takes pawn isn't
really possible because maybe you can
now get in your tactics uh i think it
might still be possible it's super sharp
maybe if we can just get the board very
quickly while uh keeping an eye on the
players
and here white has a choice white can
take this pawn it looks like it's a free
pawn but you have to calculate well and
he has done it magnus carlsen so we're
gonna see it
okay knight takes pawn here in an ideal
world black would have dropped his
knight in giving check
and suddenly winning this white rook
afterwards but the problem is
after king takes knight this bishop is
suddenly defended by its knight and
white would actually win here because he
has two pieces for a rook so instead
kokesh finding the best move
he keeps finding the best moves he just
takes this pawn and now these rooks are
looking at each other blacks rooks
threatening to invade when both sides
are down to one okay traitorous one
both sides are down to one minute
knights are the trickiest most annoying
pieces in the world
brings this rook down and checks you i
will block it in my knight
but then i can okay something yeah maybe
maybe
uh now he's the one asking questions of
kokeshi okay it's actually on the board
okay and i'm slightly concerned
oh dear we're heading straight down the
variation we were discussing so white's
pieces now
really hanging together by a thread
three seconds
he's gone for it knight takes bishop and
then rook takes
knight but now white is completely safe
i think
yeah i would actually prefer to be white
you know because suddenly i'm going to
be a porn up i'm a bit a little bit
surprised by that move
i was expecting maybe something else but
okay rick takes pawn okay
and yeah now he gets behind
the father's most pawn and attacks that
one the thing is though that your knight
does get caught
offside once you start chasing those
pawns on the edge of the board
so um okay well do you think magnus is
just simply looking for some series of
checks
i still think magnus would love a draw
right now white's pawns are too
uh i mean they're just they're so
backward aren't they
and they're so uncoordinated and there's
just no way to kind of
get them motoring and look at the white
knight yes awkward pin
yeah that white knight paralyzed right
now cannot move magnus gives a check
he's hoping for the draw here look at
magnus's body language he knows he's
been in trouble this game
okay kukesh allows a repetition of the
position for the first time
will he play for the wingerkesh can he
find a way to put magnus under pressure
or will he just allow these checks will
he take the draw
magnus is kind of silently offering in
this draw now with all these checks
can the king find a different route with
the clock ticking down
i think i think he's just going to panic
and go into the draw
what do you think david probably i would
do the same but we would love to see him
fight and he doesn't repeat the position
the decision though i would have gone
the other way maybe if anywhere
and now now there's a threat in the air
there's a threat in the other that black
is threatening rook
takes knight okay but magnus has spotted
that that is pinned
i think the white king can actually step
forward now and now
the black knight is attacked two seconds
for good question okay he made that move
with three seconds
yeah lovely lovely pin there by
magnus okay so now magnus is a pawn up
but
it should still be a draw three versus
two if you catch he needs to get active
with the black king
he needs to make sure okay he finds that
move he needs to make sure
magnus doesn't work that in game magic
seconds left on the clock
definitely not easy for him to hold this
draw anymore the longer magnus can kind
of nurse that
he now goes active with his rook the
longer this doesn't change
the more kakesh will get nervous also
the clock situation
okay he attacks the pawn white's rook is
just going to check that black king away
and uh that black king will be forced to
retreat
all right and with the clock situation
i'm getting nervous for a good cashier
instead he
uh now he's forced to defend and white's
king going active
yeah sometimes you're dead winning one
move later you're forced to defend a
horrible end game
how can white make progress how can
white try and win this game okay he
gives check
and now pawn takes yeah it's not that
easy
for white to make progress now now that
the black king has
nicely centralized itself and is in
prime position to defend
its porn kind of take revenge for all
that suffering he had earlier in the
game
to actually because then white's rook
will go after the black pawn so the
black king has to stay near
its own pawn porn that uh white has the
the pawn on the g
line that is actually quite a terrible
pawn to have it's the central pawn that
you want to keep
um just an easy easy eyes closed draw
yeah no way to win if it's just a g pawn
alone for white
king's pawn on the e line that is the
potential winner for white white central
pawn the past pawn
that's a nice move but okay you still
have rook check now we need a few stages
right so
so first of all magnus improves the rook
so the rook can give
cover if needed i think the best end
game players they know when to
accelerate the play but when to just
kind of take your time out
just slowly improve or slowly wait and
gain down a pawn no
down a pass pawn when your opponent's
king is active the king has
made its bid for freedom okay so now
we're expecting well how to check
okay well rick well chooses to
check from behind but magnus just blocks
it from the side
i'm going to check you from the side and
rook end games there's we talk about
checking distance sometimes you always
want at least
three rows between your rook and the
opponent's king so the opponent can't
run towards your rook it's harder for
your opponent to block
and here kakesh is perfectly this is
impressive end game technique
by the youngster magnus he's trying all
these different techniques they're not
quite working yet no breakthrough
cash giving check there if the white
king steps forward you'll continue
checking
yeah from the side exactly it's so
important you can check from behind but
you also got to remember
check from the side and magnus stepping
backwards with the king
well magnus really not making any
progress largely thanks to gagesh's
amazing defense this is tenacious stuff
from the teenager
and magnus again just making moves no
immediate plan
i think he's just trying to gain a bit
of time on the clock look at magnus he's
up to almost two minutes
earlier he was under one minute so he's
just gonna try and maybe get through
four minutes on the clock and then find
a plan
but it does mean kokesh is going to gain
time as well yeah
actually um i was told that it's uh
one some grandmaster's strategy that
you make nonsense moves you don't know
non-moves non-muslims
yeah and lol your opponent into a false
sense of danger
and then you set the trap
yeah and uh magnus will set a trap at
some point
if he can but right now still no
progress the white rock dancing around
the black king
stepping forward and yep
okay finally there's a move there's a
pawn move a pawn push
a hot streak yeah very cool and okay the
black king's stepping forward
magnificent so far um absolutely
he makes it look so easy okay but here's
the decision brooke is always going to
threaten to check the white king from
behind or from the side
you can always give it up if you need to
so um okay
white's rook does continue checking the
black king no progress here
at all for magnus carlsen cash
how calm is he like i mean especially
after just the
just the path of the game just the
general
just the general trend it all was in his
favor suddenly turned against him but he
has adapted
immediately onto the defensive
refusing to back down and uh have to say
one of the dangers
with white advancing their pawn in the
middle too far up the board
is that the pawn actually gives the
white king some shelter from some of the
checks
porn if you really want to but yeah
check makes sense
and another check right now i mean i
don't see any reason not to give a check
okay he doesn't go for the safest option
he goes for a pawn but magnus says i'm
going to give up that pawn
and okay now it's a bit of a race
white's king going active
trying to support its past pawn so white
taking some risk but black can just
bring his rook behind that pawn i think
and black now
will you have his own uh his own trump
card his own pawn will start running as
well so
still within the realms of draw yeah
definitely and uh the rook will now
the black rook will now get behind the
white pawn he'll delay as long as
possible he'll happily give up his rook
for white's point
and the black king and pawn together
will march down the board
so yeah when in doubt give a check your
cash does that
we actually had a draw like that didn't
we david yeah
a long time ago it was a long long time
ago
now black just needs to keep tracking
okay he doesn't do that he doesn't need
to do that
he pushes the pawn and it's going to be
too slow for white
white's going to push his pawn black's
king's going to step forward now
to support its pawn and then black will
just give up his rook
happily yeah both pawns are going to
cost
the opponent their rooks and we'll end
up with king versus king in that one
oh magnus trying to be sneaky here he's
inviting
he's inviting uh actually even rook
takes rook would be a draw there but you
definitely don't allow your play to make
a queen
so um bukesh just keeping his rook for
now not getting distracted away
from the white pawn and
yeah i think we'll see a draw within the
next minute or so
okay here he comes next 20 seconds or so
exactly
rick takes and now the pawn will start
advancing and just look
the white king is just helpless too
exactly you know the action is happening
on the right and
the right work cannot fand off both the
king and the pawn
so there you go okay where is the king
uh kukash why what is that reaction
about i think he's unhappy i think he
knew he had a big advantage
wow and or maybe he's just shattered
after such an exhausting game but it's
an important point
it's an important